- Let the function f be defined by
f of x is equal to ax to the third plus b,
where a and b are constants.
If f of zero is equal to two,
and f of two is equal to three,
which of the following must be true?
And it's a is greater than zero,
b is greater than zero,
a is less than b, so let's
look at each of these
constraints right over here.
So, we have f of x is equal
to ax to the third plus b.
And they say f of zero, so
what is f of zero going to be?
F of zero, well this
whole term is gonna be
a times zero to the third, so
that's just going to be zero.
So, f of zero's going to be equal to b,
which they tell us is equal to two,
so we know that b is equal to two.
So, now we know that
f of x is equal to ax
to the third plus two.
Then they tell us f of two is three.
Well, what is f of two?
And I'll just switch colors
somewhat arbitrarily.
F of two, now, is going to be
a times two to the third power plus two.
Well, this is going to be equal to
eight a plus two, and they tell us,
they tell us that that is equal to three.
That is equal to three.
So, we have eight a plus
two is equal to three.
Now we can solve for a, actually,
so let's subtract two from both sides
and we get eight a is equal to,
eight a is equal to one,
divide both sides by eight,
a is equal to one-eighth.
So, which of these are true?
A is greater than zero, that's true.
B is greater than zero, that's true.
A is less than b,
one-eighth is less than two,
that's true as well,
so all three are true.